[Music]
2016 is coming to a close which means
it's time to leave video game land
behind and spend the holidays with
Grandma December was home to both the
game awards and PlayStation experience
so we got plenty of new trailers and
announcements and some more far more
memorable than others let's get to the
top 10 stories shall we number 10
uncharted 4 story dlc if you thought
naughty dog was done with uncharted 4
you'd be wrong The Lost Legacy is a
standalone story chapter one that the
developer says is shorter than uncharted
for itself but longer than the last of
us is left behind expansion Chloe Fraser
was strangely absent from the most
recent game but she na Dean are taking
the reins this time as the reveal
trailer showed them exchanging fists
with some military guards will
definitely be hearing more about this
lost chapter soon number 9 knack to
announced speaking of games you thought
were finished knack is coming back with
a sequel that you probably weren't
asking for designer mark cerny said
there's a lot of room to explore in that
world and if the reveal trailer is
anything to go by part of that
exploration means playing the game in
coop no release date was given but
nacked two will likely be headed
exclusively to ps4 number 8 pewdiepie's
deleted channel when it comes to YouTube
there's no name bigger than PewDiePie
his videos were already some of the most
popular on the site but the youtuber
vowed to delete his entire channel if he
reached 50 million subscribers then he
hit that milestone and true to his word
PewDiePie deleted his channel except it
wasn't his primary channel but rather an
alternate account with far less views
and subscribers that Swede is an expert
troll number 7 death strandings new
trailer the gaming world loves Hideo
Kojima but more than that they love
dissecting his trailers new footage at
PSX revealed both Guillermo del Toro and
mads mikkelsen and game plus a bunch of
shots of baby dolls and tanks and weird
pinnacles kijima later said the trailer
was full of quote various hints and
this leads so the internet started
digging through the footage again at
this point we should probably just wait
for some real gameplay details number
six marvel vs capcom infinite revealed
you should know by now that a lot of
games were announced at PSX and you can
add marvel vs capcom infinite to the
list the debut footage looked gorgeous
as Ryu Mega Man Iron Man and miss marvel
all duked it out on a rooftop a second
trailer also confirmed captain america
and more again for the roster the
fighter is coming to ps4 xbox one and pc
sometime in 2017 but if you can't wait
until then Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3
is available at a reduced price on ps4
right now number five Super Mario runs
bittersweet launch the most famous video
game character is on one of the most
popular mobile devices in the world so
super mario run should be a win-win
right analyst group super data even
predicted it would make 60 million
dollars in its first month but super
mario runs launched wasn't too hot it
tops 10 million downloads on day one but
the ten dollar price tag and always
online requirement were not very well
received as of this video the game is
sitting at a two-and-a-half star rating
nintendo shares fell and super data
lowered its projection to only 15
million in the first month sorry Mario
number 4 remastered PlayStation classics
speaking of games coming to new
platforms a whole batch of PlayStation
classics are making their way to ps4 we
already knew that the crash bandicoot
games were being remastered but we got
our first look at the insane trilogy at
PSX on the same stage sony also
announced the wipeout omega collection
plus ps4 remasters for Parappa the
rapper patapon and loco roco you've got
to be a fan of at least one of those and
now you'll be able to play the
definitive version number three more
nintendo switch games announced Nintendo
had its own list of games to announce
too we already knew that Zelda breath of
the wild in lego city undercover we're
coming to the switch but that's not all
Dragon Quest 11 has also been confirmed
for the system and banjo kazooie
spiritual successor ukele
Lee has been canceled on Wii U in favor
of a switch version to indie games
seasons of heaven and the sacred hero
are both coming in 2018 and it's just a
few short weeks until Nintendo's big
switch live stream where we'll hear even
more about the official launch lineup
number 2 all the holiday events it is
that time of year and video games all
over have been getting into the holiday
spirit destiny's the dawning
reintroduces the sparrow racing league
street fighter 5 has new holiday
costumes hit man's paris map has been
updated with christmas trees and new
targets the list just goes on and on and
of course gamespot's own game of the
year overwatch got a batch of new
costumes sprays voice lines and all
sorts of presence with the winter
wonderland update it really is the most
wonderful time of the year number 1 The
Last of Us sequel confirmed we're going
back to PSX with this one the last of us
can certainly stand on its own but
Sony's showcase ended with the reveal of
the last of us part 2 Ellie's all grown
up joel is getting up there and that's
really all we know the game is in very
early stages of development after all
but the team at Naughty Dog is loaded
with master storytellers so we expect
big things no release window has been
given but don't be surprised to see this
coming exclusively to ps4 and those are
the biggest stories of December with
that we're closing out the year join us
in 2017 for more video game news reviews
gameplay videos and anything else you
could want from all of us here at
gamespot we hope you had a happy holiday
and a great new year
you
[Music]
you